I was like mom and she goes this god I
remember it the school just called Adams
dead so we only moved into this place
about five months ago so and this little
cave here is kind of my like inspiration
space I've got my little village here of
stuff from all around the world given to
me for all kinds of reasons as the CEO
believed limited I travel a lot and I'm
in production a ton at believe we went
from creating a program aimed at young
people in the u.s. to a feature
documentary that I'm extraordinarily
proud of typical day I'm up by 6:30 it's
already 9:30 on the East Coast come
downstairs have that cup of coffee I
step outside I spend time in my garden I
water our plants and then I pop upstairs
by 8 a.m. I'm in my office and it is
emails phone calls this is Patrick
writing notes transcribing notes from
the whiteboard whether I'm here in Los
Angeles or traveling around the world
one thing that I have made sure is
always with me
it's my medication and every other day
no matter what I have to take my
medication this is it these are the six
tools so this drug essentially replaces
what my body doesn't naturally produce
my liver doesn't make the proteins that
help blood vessels seal up when they've
been burst which actually happens all
the time
this puts those proteins into my body so
that I essentially operate like a normal
person that little seven minute process
was all Adam needed to do
to save his own life
[Music]
it was just the two of us we were two
years apart our parents got divorced
when we were both really young
we both had this rare disease hemophilia
that none of our friends had and no one
else in our family had so like that was
nice I had some challenges related to
Murphy Leah there were seven years in
particular where I was bleeding a lot
I was home a lot on the couch missing
school during those times my brother was
one of my only social outlets and he was
also the only other person I knew who
got it who like knew what a bleed felt
like it gave me such a sense of comfort
I have no idea how I would have turned
out without Adam he was my teammate and
he was he was an excellent teammate I
was in an acting conservatory and I had
go to my phone it's blown up and I don't
know why I called my mom and a colleague
picks up it gets 9:30 in the morning on
a Wednesday and my mom's like nursing
colleague is pick up the phone at home
that's not good she was like Patrick
just come home just come home I was like
what's going on you should just come
home and as I put my mother on the phone
when she came on the phone I was like
mom and she goes this god I remember at
the school just called Adams dead I in
that moment understood grief because
Adams dead is a non-negotiable statement
that's it
[Music]
that's my brother Adam it's funny
doesn't get easier let you get used to
it
he took some kind of minor head injury
we actually don't know exactly what
happened the medicine was in duffle bag
under his bed three feet away from where
his head was
this was life-sustaining stuff what why
what was the difference between my
brother and I he didn't identify as
having hemophilia I did I grown-up I was
the athlete I was pushing boundaries not
Adam he didn't have the identity when he
went to college it was too easy to
forget that he had hemophilia that was
the problem about two years into the
acting thing I had a chance to do this
project in New York with drug users and
recovering drug users I would go in and
interview them hear their life story
turn that into a monologue and I put a
show together based on all these stories
and I just watched the impact that that
had on the participants their peers and
I thought this is all I want to do I'm
making a difference here this is the
most important thing I've done how can I
do something like this that would affect
people like my brother I just started
doing the homework where are young
people with haemophilia who maybe don't
have an identity as being somebody with
a severe life-threatening bleeding
disorder a lot of them are watching
comedic video online why don't we put
comedic video online that just so
happens to be about haemophilia it's
like my gym teacher doesn't need to
treat me like a bubble girl just because
I have von Willebrand's how does that
make you feel
we've now been making stop the bleeding
for five years across eight seasons
which includes 49 episodes starting a
couple years ago we also had all of our
episodes transcribed and re-recorded in
Spanish and distributed it to the global
spanish-speaking audience so that was
the first project stop the bleeding was
very well received right away so we
developed a workbook and an activity in
a workshop session and then either for
groups of teenagers or kids or full
families I'd show them episodes of the
show we would talk about its teams kind
of break it apart and just engage in a
live event experience together that
started going really well so then there
was more interest in what else could you
guys do for you know the local community
here in North Dakota or Houston Texas or
in Hawaii
there was actually a kid a few months
ago in Michigan he was so into the
screening his parents just said to me
like thank you so much for creating this
show he gets bullied at school he has
trouble identifying himself and seeing
himself in the world and this show gives
him a sense of security and grounding
that's all I need that kid feels a
little safer in the world I've done my
job then a couple years after my
presence in the community grew we made a
documentary about the haemophiliac
Mountaineers historic climb of Everest
in the Seven Summits while raising
awareness and money for his blood
brothers in developing countries we feel
it looks very different in other places
in the world
people with the same condition that I
have aren't making it past 10 years old
Bombardier blood is a feature-length
documentary about
haemophiliac Mountaineer Kriss
Bombardier and his historic mission to
climb Mount Everest and the Seven
Summits it shows what you can accomplish
with hemophilia in 2018 if you have
access to medicine and proper care but
in Everest own home country of Nepal
most kids they're dying of hemophilia
before age 10 for them life with
hemophilia is a death sentence and I
hate to say that but it's true every one
of Chris's Seven Summits climbs has been
connected to a fundraiser to get
sponsorships for these kids through save
one life which is a nonprofit
organization he belongs to these
sponsorships mean that families are able
to have a refrigerator in their house so
they might be able to store a little bit
of medicine because they live eight
hours from the only hospital that keeps
a fractional amount even necessary it's
my position that if stopped the bleeding
and believe limited really was around
when my brother was alive that he would
still be alive
I think about Adam and like why I'm
doing all this ideas are big man ideas a
powerful all of this started with an
idea for a webseries something terrible
happened my brother caused a tremendous
amount of pain and I said I'm figuring
out how to do something with all this
you